L
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THEY DON'T WAKE UP IN THE
MORNING THINKING WE NEED A
STRONG PARTY.
>> THEY SHOULD CARE MORE ABOUT
--
>> JAKE, HERE WE ARE.
>> ALL RIGHT THERE, YOU GO.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THAT IS IT, HE HAS REACHED.
>> THE SPEAKER.
>> HE HAS REACHED THE MARGIN,
THE 215 MARGIN WITH FIVE MEMBERS
VOTING PRESENT.
THE THRESHOLD GOES DOWN FROM 218
TO 215.
AND WE HAVE THERE KEVIN
McCARTHY, CONGRESSMAN KEVIN
McCARTHY.
THE REPUBLICAN FIRST ELECTED TO
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
IN 2006.
HE HAS BEEN SERVING AS A LEADER
SINCE THEN.
AND HE WINS ON THE 15th BOUT,
BECOMING THE 55th PERSON TO
SERVE AS SPEAKER OF THE U.S.
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
15 BALLOTS.
THIS IS THE LONGEST PROCESS IN
164 YEARS AND THE ONLY TIME IT
HAS LASTED THIS LONG SINCE THE
U.S. CIVIL WAR.
McCARTHY WON UGLY.
HE WON BY MAKING CONCESSION
AFTER CONCESSION.
HE WON IN A PROCESS THAT WAS, AT
TIMES, CHAOTIC AND ANGRY AND
ONCE ALMOST DOWN RIGHT VIOLENT.
BUT THE KEYWORD IN THIS SENTENCE
IS THE WON, KEVIN McCARTHY WON.
HE IS NOW THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
IT IS HISTORY, IT IS MAYBE
HISTORY FOR THE WRONG REASONS
FOR SOME FOLKS, BUT IT IS
HISTORY.
>> IT IS.
AND YOU KNOW, ONE OF HIS ALLIES
WAS TEXTING ME AS IT WAS GOING
BACK AND FORTH AND BACK AND
FORTH AND WE SAW THE DRAMA, AND
THIS PERSON JUST SAID KEEP YOUR
EYE ON THE BALL FOR HIM AND THE
BALL IS WINNING.
AND THE BALL IS THIS MOMENT.
AND THE BALL IS BECOMING SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE.
AND THE ROLLER COASTER,
OBVIOUSLY, WAS QUITE TUMULTUOUS
TONIGHT.
TO THINK ABOUT THE JOURNEY HE
TOOK AND PUT HIMSELF ON,
PARTICULARLY THROUGH THE TRUMP
YEARS IN ORDER TO GET TO THIS
MOMENT.
>> INDEED.
AND YOU KNOW, I THINK THE OTHER
THING I'M FLASHING BACK TO IS
WHAT KEVIN McCARTHY HAS BEEN
SAYING TO REPORTERS, WHICH IS
IT'S NOT HOW YOU START, IT'S HOW
YOU FINISH.
FRANKLY, THE NIGHT IS FINISHING
THE WAY THEY EXPECTED, BUT IT
DID NOT GO THE WAY THEY EXPECTED
WHEN THEY WALKED ON.
>> THAT'S HIS FAMILY.
>> CAN I JUST SAY ONCE MORE,
THIS IS TWO YEARS SINCE JANUARY
6th.
AND WHAT WAS GOING ON IN THE
HOUSE THAT DAY, AND HOW MANY OF
THESE MEMBERS WERE ELECTION
DENIERS OR VOTED TO STOP THE
PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER.
>> INCLUDING THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, THE NEW SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
>> -- OF THE MEMBERS ELECT WHO
DID NOT ANSWER THE FIRST CALL OF
THE ROLL.
>> I THINK THERE IS ONE DEMOCRAT
THAT WAS OUT.
>> VINCENTE GONZALEZ.
JEFFERIES.
>> WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
ROSENDALE.
>> ROSENDALE.
>> PRESENT.
>> THERE IT IS, PRESENT.
SO SIX PRESENT VOTES.
ALL SIX OF THE REBELS, THE FINAL
HOLOUTS VOTED PRESENT, WHICH
LOWERED THE THRESHOLD NECESSARY
FOR McCARTHY.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO WIN 218, 216
WAS JUST FINE.
>> FROM A TACTICAL PERSPECTIVE
THIS IS A WIN FOR KEVIN
McCARTHY.
I THINK NOW EVEN AT THIS HOUR IT
IS IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THE LONG
TERM, THE BIGGER PICTURE HERE IS
THAT HE IS PERHAPS GOING TO BE
THE WEAKEST SPEAKER IN MODERN
HISTORY BEHOLDEN TO A VERY,
VERY, VERY SMALL PORTION OF HIS
CONFERENCE.
A GROUP OF PEOPLE, WHO AS WE SAW
TONIGHT, HE CAN'T EVEN REALLY
TRUST.
SO IT'S A, I THINK, A
BITTERSWEET MOMENT FOR HIM
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE GOING
TO BE AS EVERYONE WAKES UP
TOMORROW MORNING, WHAT IS THIS
SPEAKERSHIP GOING TO LOOK LIKE,
WHAT IS THIS MAJORITY GOING TO
LOOK LIKE, AND WHAT IS THE
COUNTRY GOING TO BE GOING
THROUGH OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
AS THEY HAVE TO GOVERN.
>> AND WHAT DID HE PROMISE THEM.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
CONCESSIONS WERE.
WHAT WAS MATT GAETZ PROMISED IN
THE END AND FOR HIS VOTE AS
WELL.
WE'RE GOING TO BE FINDING THIS
OUT NOT JUST IN WEEKS BUT DOWN
THE ROAD WHAT HE PROMISED THEM.
>> WE WERE TOLD AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE NIGHT THAT THE VOTE ON
THE RULES PACKAGE WOULD PROCEED
AFTER THE VOTE ON THE
SPEAKERSHIP.
THIS WAS AT A TIME THAT WE
THOUGHT IT WAS ONLY GOING TO GO
TO 14 BALLOTS AND WAS GOING TO
CONCLUDE AN HOUR OR SO AGO AND
WITHOUT ANYBODY ALMOST PUNCHING
MATT GAETZ IN THE FACE.
BUT WE ARE HERE NOW AND I THINK
WE'RE BEING TOLD THAT THE RULES
PACKAGE WILL BE VOTED ON MONDAY
AND NOT TODAY, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> WE BELIEVE SO.
I DON'T THINK IT'S DEFINITELY
DECIDED YET.
BEFORE THAT HAPPENS, WE HAVEN'T
SEEN KEVIN McCARTHY ACTUALLY GET
THE GAVEL.
>> RIGHT.
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS ACTUALLY SWORN IN.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN HERE AND
WE'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS SERIES
OF 15 VOTES, INCLUDING BY
MEMBERS ELECT, BUT THEY ARE
STILL MEMBERS ELECT EVEN AT THIS
MOMENT.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN SWORN IN TO
OFFICIALLY BECOME MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> YEAH, SO THERE IS STILL THE
OFFICIAL VOTE TO BE COUNTED, TO
BE CALLED BY THE READERS AND BY
THE CLERK.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, THE
OFFICIAL SWEARING IN OF THIS
CONGRESS, AFTER WHICH WE
ANTICIPATE, ALTHOUGH GOOD
MONEY'S ON NOT MAKING ANY BETS
THESE DAYS, WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THERE WILL BE A MOTION TO
ADJOURN, JOHN?
>> WE MAY FIRST HEAR, THOUGH,
FROM SPEAKER McCARTHY AND THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADER, HAKEEM
JEFFERIES.
>> YES, I ANTICIPATE THAT AS
WELL.
WE DID SEE SPEAKER McCARTHY
MOUTH THE WORD FINALLY JUST A
FEW MINUTES AGO.
BUT AMERICA IS ABOUT TO HEAR A
LOT MORE FROM THIS MAN WHO IS
NOW THIRD IN LINE TO THE
PRESIDENCY.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> GREENE WAS ONE OF THOSE
MEMBERS THAT WAS --
>> KICKED OFF COMMITTEES, KICKED
OFF HER COMMITTEES NOT LONG AGO
BECAUSE OF VIOLENT RHETORIC THAT
SHE HAD USED AGAINST MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, INCLUDING NANCY PELOSI
AND ALL SORTS OF THINGS SHE HAD
SAID THAT WERE ANTI-SEMITIC AND
RACIST AND ON AND ON.
SHE IS GOING TO BE A STAR IN THE
McCARTHY REIGN, HAVING STOOD BY
HIS SIDE DURING THE ENTIRE TIME,
EVEN WHILE HER FELLOW MAGA MAGA
CAUCUS MEMBERS CAUSED LOTS OF
PROBLEMS FOR HIM.
>> SHE'S A PRIME EXAMPLE OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN HAPPEN THIS WEEK.
HE HAS OFFERED CONCESSIONS, AND
PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN THEM THEIR
VOTES.
HE OFFERED HER A PLACE ON THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, SHE
SUPPORTED HIM THROUGH AND
THROUGH THIS.
I WAS GOING TO SAY, SHE WAS ALSO
ONE OF THE LIAISONS HELPING
FACILITATE THE CALLS BETWEEN
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
MEMBERS AS THAT CHAOS WAS
BREAKING OUT ON THE FLOOR ABOUT
HALF AN HOUR AGO.
>> AND THE RELATIONSHIP TOO
BETWEEN THEM IS ALSO, YOU KNOW,
THE SIDE EFFECT, ONE OF THE SIDE
EFFECTS OF THAT PICTURE THAT
McCARTHY WENT DOWN AND TOOK WITH
DONALD TRUMP AT MAR-A-LAGO.
I MEAN, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN
WHICH ORDER OR WHO WAS HELPED
THE MOST BY WHAT UNFOLDED THAT
DAY.
>> LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> THE TOTAL NUMBER OF VOTES
CAST IS 428 OF WHICH THE
HONORABLE KEVIN McCARTHY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS RECEIVED
216.
THE HONORABLE HAKEEM JEFFERIES
OF THE STATE OF NEW YORK HAS
RECEIVED 212.
WITH SIX RECORDED AS PRESENT,
THEREFORE THE HONORABLE KEVIN
McCARTHY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVING RECEIVED A
MAJORITY OF THE VOTES CAST IS
DUALLY ELECTED SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
[ APPLAUSE ]